[Musique]
merci
Dominique d'être avec nous pendant cette
première demi-heure vous êtes élu des
altes maritimes membres du groupe les
républicains et vous présidez la
commission des affaires économiques ici
au Sénat vous êtes également rapporteur
de la mission d'information sur la crise
du logement on va en parler dans
quelques instants d'abord l'actualité
aujourd'hui c'est cet hommage national
qui est donc rendu aux victimes
françaises des attaques du Hamas le 7
octobre dernier 4 mois après donc les
attaque arrive cet hommage est-ce que
c'est trop tard pour vous on peut se
poser la question pour autant je salue
cette cérémonie d'hommage national au 42
victimes françaises ainsi qu'aux otages
il était important et je souligne quand
même que la France est le premier pays à
rendre un hommage national après je
déplore ce qui s'est passé au travers de
la polémique avec la présence des
députés de la France insoumise je les
appelle effectivement à plus de décence
plus d'indignité alors qu'ils n'ont
jamais jamais condamner la barbarie et
jamais condamner le Hamas comme une
organisation terroriste la qualifiant
même de mouvement de résistance et je
comprends tout à fait le malaise qui a
pu saisir et l'émotion les familles des
victimes mais ce que je voudrais retenir
ne devrait pas y aller pour vous moi je
pense qu'il n'aurait pas dû y aller la
décence les aurait amené à refuser
l'invitation qui a été rendue de façon
républiquaine par le Président de la
République mais pour autant j'espère que
l'on retiendra de cette matinée qui va
être fortément empris emprinte d'émotion
et bien que la France est unie est
debout et qu'elle rend cet hommage
national face à la barbarie islamiste
face à l'antisémitisme et face à
l'horreur absolue qu' a été ce pogrom le
7 octobre dernier l'Élysée envisage
également un temps mémoriel pour les
français morts dans les bombardements
israéliens à Gaza est-ce que ça vous
paraît nécessaire ça vous paraît
justifié non je dirais que ça ne me
paraît pas justifié on a vu he tout au
long de ces semaines écoulées les
polémiques qui pouvaient naître deci de
là aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de commune
mesure entre ce qui s'est passé en
Israël ce poram Porom cette horreur
absolue et malheureusement effectivement
aussi des victimes civil dans la bande
de Gaza mais je ne mets pas les choses
au même niveau et je pense que l'hommage
national doit être rendu uniquement aux
victimes françaises et à l'ensemble des
victimes de ce pogrom ainsi que aux
otages il faut pas oublier qu'il y a
toujours un certain nombre de personnes
qui sont retenues en otage plus de 4
mois après cette attaque barbare on va
parler d'un autre sujet de la crise
agricole est-ce que selon vous les
mesures qui ont été annoncées par
Gabriel hatal en fin de semaine dernière
sont les bonnes alors d'abord je dirais
que au niveau du Sénat et plus
particulièrement de mon groupe nous
n'avons pas été surpris par cette crise
agricole la commission des affaires
économiques depuis de nombreux mois
travaill sur ces sujets-là en 2019 elle
avait déjà a rendu un rapport sur le
mal-être des agriculteurs avec la
question du suicide des agriculteurs
puis il y a eu une proposition de loi
sur la compétitivité agricole de la
ferme France donc autant de mesures qui
étaient déjà sur la table et qui nous
laissaiit penser que la crise allait
véritablement se déclarer et être
particulièrement grave alors on a vu les
mesures annoncées par le premier
ministrees attendons de voir parce que
dans ces mesures il y a un certain
nombre de mesures qui ont eu un effet
immédiat là il y en a d'autres qui
s'inscrivent soit dans le cadre
réglementaire soit surtout un certain
nombre de ces mesures qui doivent faire
l'objet d'un véhicule législatif je vous
rappelle qu'il y avait un véhicule
initialement qui était prévu sur le
projet de loi orientation et Avenir
agricole qui devait finalement traiter
de peu de choses la transmission des
entreprises c'est un sujet important
mais pas au regard de la crise du de la
crise du agricole et puis qui devait
traiter du renouvellement des
générations alors on verra ce qu'il y
aura dans ce nouveau projet euh de loi
mais force de constater qui été décalé
justement pour rajouter notamment des
mesures de simplificationou voà entre
autres simplification mais il devrait
aussi avoir des mesures sur la
compétitivité agricole et j'espère aussi
qu'il y aura des mesures sur le mal-être
agricole sur cette agribaching dont sont
victimes les agriculteurs je pense en
particulier aux intrusions dont ils font
l'objet sur leurs exploitations et puis
enfin il y a des mesures qui sont
entendues au niveau européen parce
qu'aujourd'hui cette crise agricole ce
désarroie des AGR culteur il se traduit
par cette Europe qui met à mal notre
souveraineté alimentaire en
surtransposant un certain nombre de
règles à l'intérieur de notre pays alors
que à l'extérieur de notre pays on ouvre
tout grand les portes ouais on va en
parler et si certains barrages si
beaucoup de barrages d'ailleurs ont été
levés certains agriculteurs poursuivent
leurs actions notamment dans les grandes
surfaces c'est le cas en andréloire
notamment à Chinon et à looche on va
regarder ce reportage de Clémence d'que
pour nos partenaires de tvtour valdloire
[Musique]
pas forcément facile à
voir les barrages ont été levés mais le
terrain reste occupé des agriculteurs
siillnent ici les rayons de ce magasin
Leclerc àchinon dans leur viseur les
produits importés et leurs étiquettes
trompeuses une action en réponse à
l'annonce du renforcement de
l'application de la loi
égalim Bruno Leem a annoncé 10000
contrôles des prix des traçabilités au
travers de la loi Galim modestement on
va on va l'aider à faire cette cette
action et cet engagement et
régulièrement probablement même
quotidiennement nous aurons des
contrôles de prix et d'origine dans les
dans les grandes surfaces dans les
prochains jours le gérant du magasin a
été prévenu s'il lui est possible de
créer des alliances locales pour
proposer des produits de proximité les
consommateurs restent attachés aux
marques on a beaucoup de fissurs locaux
au niveau des fruites et légumes
principalement au niveau du vinion
biticole donc bon au niveau des grandes
marques moi la su j'ai pas j'ai pas la
vision nous on achète les grandes
marques carta mission voilà et puis les
clients les clients les demandent aussi
donc les agriculteurs sont restés sur
place toute la journée la même action
s'est tenue à loche est-ce que vous
comprenez ce type d'action Dominique est
alors je sais pas s'il faut en venir à à
ce type d'action ce qui est sûr
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a encore des
problèmes dans les négociations
commerciales entre les industriels
agroalimentaires et la grande
distribution c'est tout l'objet des lois
etgalimes ces lois etgalimes il y en a
eu trois en 2018 en 2 21 et en 2023 ce
ne sont pas des mauvaises lois bien au
contraire moi je pense que ce sont des
bonnes lois des lois qui vont dans le
bon sens parce qu'elle vise à payer au
juste prix la matière première agricole
à pouvoir faire en sorte que le revenu
des agriculteurs soit protégé la le
paradoxe c'est que ces lois ne sont pas
appliquées à la lettre donc il faut pas
les revoir il faut veiller à leur bonne
appli déjà veillé à ce qu'elle soit
appliquée strictement et permettez-moi
de dire que je suis un peu surprise
qu'il faille la crise agricole d'une
telle gravité pour que le ministre de
l'Économie Bruno Lemer annonce qu'il va
renforcer les contrôle comme le disaent
d'ailleurs des syndicalistes dans ce
reportage et qu'il va sanctionner mais
pourquoi ne l'a-t-il pas fait avant la
première loi égalime je vous l'ai dit
elle date de 2018 elle a 6 ans donc les
contrôles on pouvait d'ors et déjà les
opérer depuis bien longtemps les
renforcer et bien évidemment sanctionner
quand il y a contournement de la loi
égalim parce que euh certains acteurs de
la grande distribution ont trouvé le
moyen de contourner les lois égalim et
en particulier à travers le rôle des
centrales d'achat dans l'Union
européenne qui se trouve à l'étranger à
l'extérieur de notre pays et qui
permettent à certains acteurs de la
grande distribution d'acheter en gros
des produits de faire des économies
d'échelle très importantes et de
s'affranchir des contraintes qui ont été
é posé par la loi égalime donc je
regrette que les contrôles ne se fassent
que maintenant même s'il faut continuer
à en faire mais il faut aussi qu'il soit
suivi de sanctions parce que pour
certains grands groupes des sanctions
qui sont encore pour certaines assez
modestes au regard de leur chiffre
d'affaires ne sont peut-être pas de
nature à les inciter véritablement à
respecter la loi là Bruno LEM parle de 2
% du chiffre d'affaires pour vous c'est
pas assez il faut aller plus loin bah ça
dépend aussi du de l'acteur de la grand
contribution auxquell on a affaire et au
regard du chiffre d'affaires je pense
que pour certains les 2 % ne sont pas
suffisants en tout cas pour les
dissuader de continuer à contourner les
lois égalit sur l'Europe justement pour
éviter ce que vous dites à savoir que il
y a des centrales d'achat en dehors de
la France Emmanuel Macron propose un
égalisme Européen est-ce que pour vous
c'est la bonne solution et est-ce que
c'est réaliste alors d'une part je pense
que ce n'est pas forcément dire qu'il ne
faut plus qu'il y ait des centrales
d'achat au niveau européen mais que les
règles soient les mêmes partout et ce
qu' faut faire c'est qu'il faut vraiment
clarifier le droit pour savoir ce
qu'elles peuvent faire et ce qu'elles ne
peuvent pas faire après parler comme l'
annoncer le président de la République
d'un égalisme au niveau européen c'est
pas une mauvaise idée c'est pas une
mauvaise idée est-ce qu'on y arrivera
parce que là encore c'est extrêmement
compliqué de mener des négociations au
niveau des des 27 ça prendra du temps ça
prendra du temps mais si c'est de nature
effectivement à faire en sorte que ça
concerne tous les secteurs industriels
de l'Union européenne et surtout pour
éviter une distorsion de concurrence que
ce soit tant pour les producteurs que
pour les consommateurs ça va plutôt dans
le bon sens mais bien évidemment ce sont
des mesures qui ne verront pas le jour
immédiatement et donc il faut d'ici là
pouvoir trouver des solutions pour qu'il
n'y ait plus de contournement de ces
lois etgalimes qui vont dans le bon sens
je rappellerai aussi que notre
commission des affaires économiques
avait déjà pressenti le fait que l'on
pouvait contourner à à certaines
conditions les lois égalimes c'est la
raison pour laquelle a été mise en place
un groupe de suivi qui est donc mené par
une sénatrice Anne canrine noisier et
Daniel grémier qui sont très au faites
de ces sujetsl qui vont reprendre leurs
travaux et qui vont de nouveau vérifier
et voir encore ce qui ne va pas ou
comment est-ce qu'on peut faire en sorte
que la loi soit véritablement appliquée
à la lettre on va parler de la question
du logement sujet que vous suivez
évidemment de très près dans son
discours de politique générale Gabriel
Atal a promis un choc de offre vous êtes
rapporteur on le disait de la mission
d'information du Sénat sur cette crise
du logement hier vous avez auditionné
l'ancien ministre benant apparu on va
voir tout ça avec Steve
[Musique]
Jourdan bonjour St bonjour bonjour
madamejour et hier su les sénateurs
entendent donc l'ancien ministre du
Logement Benois apparu dans ce contexte
de crise du logement et la publication
des derniers chiffres oui les chiffres
les plus récents ont été publiés par la
Banque de France la semaine dernière
alors c'est un peu casse à tous les
étages le secteur du UF est complètement
à l'arrêt chute de
23,7 % des autorisations de permis de
construire en 2023 par rapport à 2022
recul de 22 % des mises en chantier
l'année dernière les banques sont
frileuses on le sait elles prêtent de
moins en moins plus faible niveau
d'octroit de crédit immobilier depuis
2015 le logement social est en train de
boire la tasse plus de 2600000 ménag
sont en attente d'un logement c'est un
record absolu hausse de 7,5 % des
demandes en un an voilà pour le contexte
de cette audition Rian audition
organisée dans le cadre d'une mission
d'information lancée par le Sénat
comment l'ancien ministre du Logement
analyse tout ça et ben pour Benoît app
paru notre politique de logement est
resté bloquée dans les années 70 selon
lui la crise est une crise d'abord
structurel nous avons mis le paquet sur
la demande au détriment de l'offre et
mécaniquement avec la hausse de la
démographie ces dernières décennies et
bien les choses se sont un peu emballé
écoutez-le la raison principale de la
crise structurelle que connaî ce secteur
vous la connaissez aussi bien que moi
c'est un déséquilibre depuis qui perdure
entre l'offre et la demande et tant
qu'on aura une politique sous-ufreuse en
matière de production de logement en
matière de logement donc euh bah la
conséquence ce sera
mécaniquement des prix qui qui
montent c'est à moi il a aussi insisté
sur la nécessité de changer de
philosophie oui changer de philosophie
en matière de construction Benoît paru a
salué le zan le zéro artificialisation
des sols qui prévoit de réduire le
rythme auquel on bétonne les terres
selon lui il s'agit d'une réforme
importante voir même historique mais
cela implique de changer nos conceptions
de l'espace public il faut en gros
apprendre à construire vers le haut
écoutez-le changer pardon d'un
développement urbain aujourd'hui
historiquement depuis 2000 ans depuis
10000 ans à l'horizontale vert verticale
3D c'est un changement qui peut paraître
basique à prononcer comme tel parce que
la verticalité la descente la densité et
cetera et cetera on en parle depuis
effectivement très très très longtemps
mais je veux simplement le mettre moi en
rapport historique en disant qu'on est à
contreculture complète de ce que nous
avons fait depuis des centaines d'années
partout dans le monde apparu à soumis
plusieurs préconisations pour sortir de
la crise mais pour lui le problème vient
surtout aujourd'hui d'un manque pardon
de volonté politique il faut donner un
nouvel élan à notre politique de
logement écoutez-le il faut de
l'impulsion politique vis-à-vis des
banques et des assureurs parce que c'est
ça qui va être le plus compliqué je
pense il faut d'abord de l'impulsion
politique c'est tout pas besoin d'un €o
pas besoin d'une loi madame laassatrice
vous êtes d'accord c'est un problème de
de volonté politique aujourd'hui oui on
le voit euh dans ce gouvernement que ce
soit depuis 2017 ou depuis 2022 le
logement est d'abord n'a jamais été une
priorité politique et malheureusement
continue à ne pas être cette priorité
politique
malgré cette grave crise et donc
forcément s'il n'y a pas une volonté
politique on n'arrivera pas à redresser
la barre et à faire en sorte que l'on
puisse non seulement offrir à nos
concitoyens des logements les loger
mieux et les loger plus ver parmi les
les préconisations de benoî apparu
laquelle vous semble la plus
intéressante la plus importante il y a
eu beaucoup de détails beaucoup de
mesures très technique si vous devez en
retenir une seule ce serait quoi alors
d'abord je savais que beno àaru allait
nous faire des nous proposer des mesures
qui seraient disruptives ce qui est
assez intéressant d'ailleurs parce que
on a besoin aussi de mesures innovantes
qui soi plus structurel ce que je
retiendrai c'est ce qu'a dit benoî à
paru aujourd'hui il y a quatre types
d'acheteurs dans le logement trois on
dors déjà disparu a disparu l'acheteur
qui veut acheter un logement pour être
propriétaire occupant l'acheteur qui
veut acheter un logement pour le mettre
à la location c'est l'investisseur
particulier et puis les investisseurs
institutionnels c'est-à-dire les banques
les groupes d'assurance ces trois types
d'acheteurs ont disparu il reste
finalement que les institutionnels parap
public la CDC Action Logement qui ont
d'ailleurs à la demande du gouvernement
acheté en 2023 45000 logements aux
promoteurs mais ça ne peut pas durer et
pour retrouver ces types d'acheteurs il
faut faire évoluer le crédit immobilier
c'est ce qu'il a soulevé c'est assez
technique il faut que les banques jouent
le jeu pour cela il a parlé de
l'impulsion politique et derrière les
banques pourrai jouer le jeu en
proposant pas un seul dispositif de
crédit immobilier mais TR 4 C
dispositifs de crédit immobilier qui
permettent de retrouver ces types
d'acheteurs qui ont disparu ça peut être
le BRS qui est déjà en pratique mais
pour le logement social Vous savez on
dissocie le foncier du bâti et bien on
peut le faire aussi pour le logement
intermédiaire et pour le logement libre
ça peut être le démembrement entre la nu
propriété et l'usufruit ça peut être
l'accession progressive mais ça me
semble
intéressé 0 €0 loi parce qu'à la
différence ce n'est pas une politique de
subvention mais c'est une politique
d'investissement lui il part du principe
que on aura plus beaucoup d'argent à
pouvoir mettre dans la politique du
logement et que donc il faut trouver un
certain nombre d'idées et de mesures qui
viennent plutôt faire de
l'investissement plutôt que de demander
des subventions et bien permettez-moi de
dire que ça me paraît quelque chose
qu'il faut creuser que nous allons faire
dans le cadre de la mission
d'information ce qui n'exclut pas toutes
les autres mesures qui sont des mesures
plus conjoncturel qui doivent permettre
de faire repartir la le marché du
logement le parcours résidentiel qui est
bloqué aujourd'hui en particulier dans
le domaine de l'accession à la propriété
mais quand on voit que ce gouvernement a
recentré le PTZ à supprimer le Pinel pas
pour dire qu'il ne fallait pas le
supprimer mais le supprime au moment où
on a besoin de soutenir la demande donc
tout est fait à l'envers sur le le choc
de l'offre parce qu'il il a fait
plusieurs propositions Gabriel Atal dans
son discours de politique générale un
choc de l'offre où il veut créer 30000
nouveaux logements d'ici 3 ans dans 20
territoires engagés et puis il a
également parlé de la loi SRU sur la
question du logement social qu'il veut
élargir pour que les logements
intermédiaires qui profitent aux classe
moyenne soient intégrés c'est la bonne
réponse pour vous alors si vous le
permettez je dirais qu'il a pas fait
plusieurs propositions le Premier
ministre il a fait quelques propositions
il a enfin dans un discours de politique
générale parlé du logement bon c'est
déjà un premier acte c'est déjà pas mal
mais après il y a beaucoup de termes qui
sont déjà usés de termes éculés et en
particulier celui du choc de l'offre le
choc de l'offre Emmanuel Macron en
parlait déjà en 2017 ça n'a rien donné
parce que c'est pas ça qui fait baisser
les prix aujourd'hui bien sûr qu'il faut
qu'il y ait un choc de l'ofre pour faire
repartir la production de logement mais
il faut soutenir la demande parce qu'il
n'y a plus de demande en raison de la
montée des taux d'intérêt brutal 4 % en
1 an et en raison aussi du resserrement
des conditions d'octroi du crédit alors
il y a quelques donc le problème c'est
pas forcément la construction de
logement alors c'est la comment permet
aux gens de devenir propriétair DEES
logement on arrive à relancer la demande
que ce soit pour devenir locataire à
travers des logements qui sont proposés
sur le marché du logement parce qu'on en
a aussi besoin et que ce soit bien sûr
pour devenir propriétaire à travers
aussi des prix de l'immobilier qui
soient moins élevés que ce qu'on trouve
aujourd'hui qui de fait exclut non
seulement les plus fragiles les plus
précaires mais bien bien évidemment
aussi toutes les classes moyennes
alors il une proposition qui s'inscrit
plutôt dans des propositions portées par
la droite qui ont d'ailleurs fait bondir
déjà la gauche d'intégrer le quota de
logement intermédiaire dans le quota des
logements sociaux de 25 % qui doivent
être tenus alors c'est à voir à voir
parce qu'après j'ai vu des des des des
remarques qui étaient un petit peu
contradictoire c'était pas la totalité
des logements mais c'était en partie les
logements intermédiaires ce que nous on
dit hier à la fois Benoît Apparu oui il
dit qu'il y aura quand même un quotat de
logement très social à fournir voilà il
y il y a besoin il y a besoin de
logement et particulièrement de logement
très sociaux ce qu'on appelle dans notre
jargon les plai les logements
intermédiaires répondent aussi à une
demande et particulièrement dans les
territoires tendus les logements
intermédiaire s'adresse d'abord
principalement aux classes moyennes et
c'est vrai que les maires dans les
région tendus veulent continuer à en
faire parce qu'ils savent qu'ils ont une
demande pour cela et que comme ils font
des efforts aussi pour faire des
logements intermédiaires et bien bien
évidemment ils voudrait être récompensé
de ces efforts en les intégrant dans le
Côa des logements sociaux comme on a pu
intégrer à l'époque les logements en
bail réel solidaire moi ce que j'ai
retenu des auditions d'hier et ce qu'il
faudra aussi réfléchir c'est que que ce
soit le directeur général d'Altarea ou
Benoît paru ils disent plutôt que
d'intégrer les logements intermédiaires
dans le Cotat des logements sociaux il
faut les neutraliser c'est-à-dire
considérer que l'on produit des
logements intermédiaires qui ne vont pas
augmenter le nombre de logements de
résidence principale puisque vous savez
que le côat de logements sociaux est
calculé à partir du nombre de résidences
principales donc on neutralise logement
intermédiaire de façon à ce qu'on puisse
continuer à en produire sans que ça
puisse déséquilibrer le le quotat des
logements sociaux à réalisé je pense que
c'est une idée qui peut être
intéressante en tout cas on verra
comment cela sera décliné par le
gouvernement et par le futur ministre du
logement que vous attendez ah oui avec
impatience bon là c'est Christophe Béchu
qui a encore le portefeuille mais pour
vous il faut un ministre
du logement de plein exercice oui il
faut un ministre du Logement de plein
exercice on l'a jamais eu de plein
exercice on a toujours eu un ministre du
Logement rattaché à un grand ministère
donc ça fait longtemps qu'on appelle un
ministre du Logement de plein exercice
mais tout comme il faut un ministre de
la Santé tout comme il faut un ministre
des Transports et on attend toujours
finalement on se demande avoir autant de
temps entre la composition du
gouvernement àal 1 et peut-être cette
semaine le gouvernement complété à tal 2
et bien ça laisse à penser que que
finalement le président de la République
et le Premier ministre considèr que le
ministère du Logement le ministère de la
santé ou le ministère des Transports ne
sont pas des ministères si important que
ça alors que ce sont des ministères qui
sont au cœur des préoccupations des
Françaises et des Français et que vous
accepteriez si on vous propose d'être
ministre du logement non je n'accepterai
pas d'être ministre du Logement votre
nom a circulé oui je sais que mon nom a
circulé mais encore une fois je pense
que ce gouvernement est d'ors et déjà
carbonisé et devenir ministre du
logement sans avoir pu négocier quoi que
ce soit soit sans avoir pu avoir le
moindre arbitrage sans aucune marge de
manœuvre ce qui était le cas du
précédent ministre du Logement et puis
répondre à un débauchage individuel ça
ne m'intéresse absolument pas vous
craignez de nouveau débauchage chez les
républicains je ne pense pas je ne pense
pas qu'ils arriveront à faire bon un
débauchage qui a fait du buzz à travers
la personne de Rashida Dati parce que
Rachida Dati c'est une marque mais je
pense que il n'y aura pas plus de
débauchage individuel ou si c'est à la
marge de personnes qui sont sans euh
nier leurs compétences peut-être moins
connues et donc qui marqueront moins les
esprits vous sentez chez Manuel Macron
chez Gabriel Atal une volonté
d'affaiblir les républicains ah ben
force de constater que il cherche par
tous les moyens effectivement à
affaiblir notre famille politique qui
est une famille politique aujourd'hui
qui en tout cas euh fait la balance
parce qu'à l'Assemblée nationale on l'a
vu pour que les textes soi votés avec
une majorité relative et bien très
souvent ils ont eu besoin de l'apport
des républicains en ayant amendé les
textes dans le sens que nous souhaitions
et puis ici au Sénat bah les
républicains avec l'Union centriste ils
font partie de la majorité sénatoriale
et le gouvernement voit bien que s'il
veut continuer à faire en sorte que des
textes et des textes importants puissent
pouvoir avoir un suivi et un cheminement
et bien ils doivent quand même fortement
comprendre que c'est aussi la majorité
sénatorielle
qui donnera le l sur un certain nombre
de textes mais est-ce que votre ligne
visà-vis deexécutif pardon est si claire
parce que vous dites que vous êtes
clairement dans l'opposition même si
c'est une opposition constructive vous
menacez même d'une motion de censure à
l'automne mais dans le même temps vous
n'avez pas voté les députés les
républicains n'ont pas votter la motion
de censure lundi est-ce que c'est clair
alors d'abord je laisserai les députés
républicains voilà à leur difficulté
parce que c'est pas simple dans un
groupe de 62 députés dans une
environnement qui est celui de
l'Assemblée nationale ça n'a rien
comparable avec ici au Sénat où nous
sommes en majorité mais quand même sur
les principaux textes je pense au texte
sur la réforme des retraites et au
dernier texte sur l'immigration nous
avons été cohérents nous avons été
responsa et si nous avons voté ces
textes c'est parce que nous nous sommes
pas reniés pour la réforme des retraites
c'est quelque chose que portait
l'ensemble de nos candidats depuis de
très nombreuses années et que nous
revendiquion et sur l'immigration s'il
n'y avait pas eu la sanction du Conseil
constitutionnel 32 mesures allit plutôt
dans le bon sens même si nous alertions
en disant que ce ne serait pas suffisant
et qu'il faudrait qu'il y ait bien sûr
une révision de la Constitution alors
justement les centristes vos collègues
sénateurs centristes ont déposé une
proposition de loi qui reprend les
mesures du Conseil constitutionnel qui
ont été retoqué mais une partie c'est ce
que j' déjà est-ce que c'est une bonne
initiative cette proposition de loi
alors j'aurais préféré que ce soit porté
conjointement par la majorité
sénatoriale puisque le texte ici au
Sénat il a bien été voté par la majorité
sénatoriale les républicains et les
centristes B ils vous ont pas consulté
il y a pas eu de de discussion entre les
de groupes président du groupe il
faudrait poser la question un bon
président de groupe Bruno retaillot je
déplore effectivement qu'on nit pas pu
agir ensemble pour autant c'est bien que
l'Union centriste rappelle combien ils
sont attachés à ce texte de loi et à
lutter efficacement contre l'immigration
illégale et clandestine mais de notre
côté nous ne sommes pas restés les bras
ballons vous savez que à la la base du
projet de loi immigration il y avait
déjà une proposition de loi portée par
les républicains par le président de la
commission des lois par François Noël
buffet et bien nous force de cette
proposition de loi qui a cette
antériorité nous allons effectivement
redéposer la proposition de loi un petit
peu modifié par rapport à ce qui a déjà
été voté et ce que nous remettrons dans
cette proposition de loi mais qui a
quand même une antériorité au regard de
ce qu'on fait les centristes et puis
après on verra quand le texte sera
inscrit de proposition de dans la
majorité sénateur mais est-ce que vous
remettrez est-ce que vous remettrez les
mesures que n'ont pas remis les
centristes comme la caution pour les
étudiants étrangers par exemple oui on
remettra toutes les mesures qui nous
semblent bonnes pour le pays répondre
aux attentes des Françaises et des
Français et que nous avons voté est-ce
que c'est un problème pour vous que la
réforme de laame de l'aide médicale
d'État qu'a confirmé Gabriel Attal se
foisse par voir réglementaire
c'est-à-dire que le Parlement n'aura pas
son moin à dire oui c'est choquant c'est
possible c'est possible de le faire par
la voie règlementaire donc on ne va pas
attaquer le Premier ministre qui dit que
je vais faire la réforme par la voie
réglementaire puisque c'est ça lui a
donné cette possibilité après ça affiche
de nouveau une défiance un nouveau
mépris vis-à-vis du Parlement je pense
que ça aurait été l'occasion pour lui et
bien de montrer sa bonne volonté de
travailler avec le Parlement de concert
sur un sujet qui est un sujet difficile
qui est un sujet délicat qui est un
sujet qui va de nouveau animer fortement
les débats mais je pense que nous
n'aurions nous aurions souhaité que ce
débat est de nouveau lieu dans
l'hémicycle et que ça aurait été un bon
point pour Gabriel Atta att mais c'était
pas prendre le risque d'un échec pour
vous parce que c'est un texte qui ne
fait pas l'unanimité oui mais on a on en
a déjà débattu vous savez quand on débat
ça va c'est toujours mieux que de le
faire par la voie du règlement même si
on s'appuie sur un rapport qui est un
rapport important donc je pense qu'en
tout cas c'était montré une bonne
manière vis-à-vis du Parlement merci
Dominique est merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité pendant cette première
demi-heure merci St tout à l'heure